you have a look at this line right and
you compare it to what you already have
now you'll notice it's almost identical
to this line
with one difference um there's no i want
instead it's this thing okay and
the whole point of doing a recurrence
relation is to get rid of all these
integrals that you don't know how to do
until you get to an integral that you do
know how to do
so let's evaluate i want that's not so
hard you probably manage that one but
let's just do it together anyway
um this is one minus one over x
okay so we know what this becomes that's
an x that's log x
from 1 to 2. so you evaluate it at 2
first then you evaluate it at
one that's going to be zero so that's
where you get this which is a bit of a
sigh of relief okay
so then you substitute this value for i1
into this line and then you just
rearrange a little bit and you'll get
this
okay so in fact i might just i'll take a
bit of a shortcut i'll write it in here
one minus log two okay and you can see
the sole difference between this line
and this line
is that these guys have slot faces so
he's gone there
and she's come
over here okay so far so good
right now how do we then use that
so you can see what's happened now that
i have this
i've shown it okay what's on the left
hand side
has nothing to do with any kind of
integration at all okay
but we're going to use integration to
take advantage of it which is really
cool actually this is all number theory
stuff
right or whole numbers that's what the
notation implies
right so when you look at this case uh
what can we say 1 by 2
by that 2 by 3
by 2 square
oops three
and so on okay this thing
matches this okay but it's where
n approaches infinity okay because it
goes on forever
right so how do i do this right
now you have to be really really careful
and very thoughtful
about it um you've got to go all the way
back to this original integral
okay so this guy here in fact even i1
right i'll put it back on the board
what does it look like right and you
might have noticed there was an actual
diagram but it didn't explain very much
about what was going on
okay so it's this
with respect to x okay here's my
question what is that thing
okay um 1 minus 1 over x
what does it look like i'll draw you a
picture okay
um you've got a an asymptote
here at x equals zero and then you have
an asymptote
now as x approaches infinity this
becomes nothing so you're approaching
one aren't you
okay so i've got this asymptote up here
and because it's minus one over x it's
upside down from what a normal hyperbola
is
okay so you're getting this kind of [ __ ]
okay
so far so good okay now this interval is
only interested in a very particular
spot
nearly from one to two
okay so the actual area is this
that's that's a one okay but before we
go any further on that i want you to
look very carefully at what this is and
the particular characteristics it has
because it has some really useful and
unusual characteristics okay
so in between um
one and two okay we already know what
this area is
right but we don't just leave the area
we know it's actually in a little box
look at this what did i say this
vertical
height was this is on y equals one yeah
right so the horizontal
distance here is one this vertical
distance is one
right so if you like you can picture
this integral as being nestled within a
rectangle
a square actually that is one by one
unit
okay now think about that if this is
this is um
y equals one minus one over x okay
at least in this area right if i then
considered
what would happen if i did this if i say
squared okay because the values here are
nestled between zero and one
right when you square numbers that are
between zero and one do they get bigger
or smaller
they get smaller because they're all
fractions right so a number like this
which might say half
will become a quarter right so if i were
to graph this it would go like
here let's see right and if i increase
the power
it would go even lower and they would as
i as this approaches infinity
it gets lower and lower and lower right
and so exactly it's approaching zero now
what do these correspond to well these
areas
these ever smaller areas they are
i1 i2 i3 i4
i5 i6 so they're shrinking and tricking
tricky which is why this whole sum
all of these areas will be equal to
some limiting thing okay so what have i
established
okay first i said look i won
right it's between zero and one
okay is that all right because it's in
this box
in fact i don't even need to say that i
can know exactly what it's equal to
but suffice it right now once you've got
i1
because it's in this area right and
because it's the
values between zero and one um i two for
instance
right is going to be less than i one
right
and i three will be less than that again
right
so more generally speaking right i
n is going to be um
i should have said i n plus 1 will be
less than i
m right as this number gets bigger the
area gets smaller it gets lower does
that make sense
okay so therefore right i can conclude
from all of this
that not only is i one less than one
right all of them will be less than one
yeah does that make sense
so um i've got i n
is less than one right uh it's between
is in this boundary
but because i n plus one is even smaller
than that it'll be
i n plus one in there
okay are you happy with that yeah now
why did i do that the reason why i
needed this i needed
this particular integral is because
that's what i have to get rid of over
here
right i have to eliminate this because i
know what one is and i know what long
two is but i have no idea what this is i
need to be able to say something about
it and its value
right okay so now i can come to my main
line of argument
and i can say i've established that zero
is less than i n
plus one which is less than one
but of course i don't have i n plus one
here i've got one over n plus one
times that so how do i get that here i
guess i divide everything by n plus one
so that'll become still zero um
divide right and then
divide okay i'm almost there
i want to know what this thing is equal
to and i have this boundary and i have
this boundary
but i'm considering n as n gets bigger
and bigger
and bigger right as n approaches
infinity in fact
right so this thing's going to change
it's not just going to change though
it's going to get smaller this this is
the squeeze law
right if i take it
as n approaching infinity of this
and take the limit as n approaches
infinity of
this it should be less than the limit as
n approaches the infinity
of this yep okay
so what happens this guy's at a person
fitting and it's not nothing
right this is what i'm actually trying
to work out which is why it's being
squeezed and what's it being squeezed
between well look at this
this will be one over two three four
five a million
it's gonna be zero there we go
okay so on the base of this line i say
that the limit of this as n approaching
50
is zero okay so therefore
i can give my graph now because i've
done my argument about the graph
i can therefore say uh on this line here
i'll say the limit as n approaches
infinity
of this sigma notation right so you
don't have to
prove that that is
this um no i'm about to i'm about to
write that
right so i'm appealing to this line
because that's what this talks about
okay and i've i've shown this i showed
it earlier so i'm just going to keep on
progressing
now i take the limits of both sides
right equals
uh one minus log two that doesn't change
has no it's independent from n
minus the limit as n approaches infinity
of
this guy which i've just gone to all the
effort with my inequality to show
is zero right uh oops sorry
i meant to say all of this stuff in here
right um all of that
okay now this is i'm now gonna evaluate
it
and the first term is this
right and the next term is this
and i need 3 to get my pattern
and because i'm taking the limit as n
approaches infinity it just
goes i have my 1 over log 2
and then i have this which is nothing
yeah so i'm finished